[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you where I'm kicking off my
first round of the weekend by cheering
to all the people and stories that
encouraged me to drink cheers to you
Buffalo Wild Wings on your new pumpkin
spice wings now basic white girls can
eat and not have to force themselves to
throw up can't wait
cheers see you Tara Reid for getting
booted off an airplane
sucks that you're gonna be late to
literally nothing cheers to you nicole
kidman for revealing that your marriage
to Tom Cruise saved you from sexual
harassment that's the beauty of sleeping
with gay men no matter how much I drink
I never wake up sore cheers to you post
Malone for going undercover for a
charity Sun literally fooling no one a
real transformation would require a
shower
he looks stinky cheers to ariana grande
for dumping Pete Davidson but keeping
the pig that doesn't make jokes about
you on Saturday Night Live I am very
sorry about the whole thing though and I
love Saturday night life and if you guys
would read my packet it would really do
a lot for my career and I love you Pete
and I hope you're doing it okay cheers
to you FDA on banning viagra spike vape
juice not because it's dangerous but
because it's pointless please go back to
the creme brulee flavor and your
mother's basement cheers to you people
at Six Flags who made $300 for lying in
a coffin for 30 hours that's the first
time anyone at Six Flags has ever made
$10 an hour
cheers to you ASAP Rocky for being
bullied at 13 during an orgy
I was also bullied during an orgy a
woman stopped me from taking off my
clothes and said ma'am this is an Olive
Garden everyone the breadsticks and it's
a lot of white trash people so I feel at
home cheers wow that was a great
addition of cheers to you with Hannah
Dickinson you can watch our regular show
every damn day full episodes of it on
the economy central YouTube page this
week we talked about stuff like the best
episode of key & peele of all time South
Park sneak peeks and we even did a
breakdown at the hottest Halloween trend
you know we did all that
here sit there the whole time you didn't
love it one thing I live with here on
the set
[Music]